[تصفيق]
تفتكروا في كم شخص اتخرج من كمبيوتر ساينس
في اخر عشر سنين كده
عشره الاف شخص
عشرين الف شخص طيب 100 الف شخص في الحقيقه
رقم مش قريب من كده
في مليون شخص اتخرجوا من كمبيوتر في اخر
عشر سنين بس
ده مش من العالم كله ده من امريكا بس
متخيلين ان الرقم
اكيد معظمكم سمع عن حاجه اسمها الذكاء
الصناعي او ارت فشنس او حتى ايه اي قبل
كده وده اللي معظم شباب الكمبيوتر
بيشتغلوا عليه
اللي ما يعرفش الايه هو من الاخر عباره عن
شويه الات بتحاول تقلد الذكاء البشري سواء
عن طريق التفكير زينا او
هقولها لكم بطريقه تانيه تخيلوا ان ده
عباره عن مخ مبسط للانسان
المخ ده بيبدا يجمع كميه معلومات مهوله
عشان يبني بها طريقه تفكيره اللي بها
هيدينا النتيجه اللي احنا عايزينها
وطبعا كلما المعلومات دي تزيد كل اما
كفاءه النتيجه تعلى
هل ده بقى معناه ان الاي اي هيتمرد علينا
وهيدمرنا زي ما كل الناس بتقول
لا ال اي لسه مش
هتمردس بيقولوا على الايه دلوقتي او محدود
ليه بقى ده لانه ما بيعرفش يعمل غير تاسك
واحد بس والمشكله الاكبر كمان ان هو ما
بيفهمش التاسك اللي هو بيعمله ده يعني لو
كان فاهم كنا نقول ماشي فاهم لكن ده حتى
ما بيفهمش
تخيلوا ان عندنا شخصين يونج واحمد يونج ما
بيفهمش غير صيني واحمد ما بيفهمش غير عربي
يمكن حاب يبعت رسائل لاحمد بالصيني وهو
فاكر ان عادي هيفهم طبعا اول لما احمد
استلم الرساله
الهبل ده انا مش فاهم حاجه قعد يدور شويه
لحد اما الاقي كتاب في كل القوانين اللي
هتسمح له يترجم لصيني
بدا احمد يستخدم الكتاب ده ان هو يتجن
الريت في سبونس ويبعتها ثاني ليونج واول
ما ينجز
كده احمد فاهم صيني ميه ميه واحنا طبعا
عارفين ان احمد ولا فاهم صيني ولا حاجه هو
مجرد التابعه شويه قوانين
علشان يعمل
احمد ده هو هو النانو اي اي بالضبط حتى لو
احنا حاسين ان هو فاهم هو مجرد اتبع شويه
قوانين علشان يبان ان هو فاهم بقى وجامد
وكده ياه هل ده معناه ان الايه منتشر
دلوقتي اللي هو العلماء بيقولوا عليه نرو
او محدود فاشل ما لوش اي لازمه
بالعكس هو قوي قوي جدا عشان اوريكم قوته
دي هديكم كم اجزامبل لايه اي موجود دلوقتي
اول مثال معنا هو
اللي قالهم ماسك عمله طيب الرابط ده بيعمل
ايه الروبوت الجامد ده يقدر يتعامل مع
المواقف الجديده والصعبه في لحظات ومن
خلال المواقف الجديده دي بيتعلم وبيطور من
نفسه كمان
هو قريب قوي كده من البيبي يعني مثلا لو
انت وريته النار وقد ايه هي بتحرق ارجع
على طول للداتابيز بتاعته ويخزن فيها
المعلومه المهمه دي علشان اول ما يشوف نار
تاني يبعد عنها على طول من غير ما اي حد
يقول له
بس طبعا لو جيت اديت له صعب عمره ما تعرض
له زي مثلا ان هو يفهم لغه عمره ما شافها
مش هيعرف يعمل اي حاجه
جدا بس في الحقيقه في ايه تاني كده اسمه
ده دي له اي حاجه لها علاقه باللغه
وهيظبطك انت بس اساله اي سؤال
باي لغه يرجع يقوم بدور اي اي ويدور في
القوانين والمعلومات اللي عنده بعدين يرجع
لك باجابه جامده جدا لسؤالك في الحقيقه
القوانين بتاعه دي عباره عن معلومات لا
نهائيه من الانترنت يعني مثلا لو سالته
وزي ما انتم شايفين بدا يعمل كامله انتو
داكشن كل حاجه فاقل من النص دقيقه
الاسكريبت اللي انا قعدت فيها شهرين
بتتعمل قدام عينيا اقل من النص دقيقه جامد
جدا صح
طبعا انت بتستغرب هو ازاي بيطلع كده بكلام
هو عنده مخ بيفكر بيه ولا ايه
في الحقيقه كل اللي اتشات جي بي تي بي
بيعمله ان هو بيبدا
يعمل كم كلمه على سؤالك بعد كده يرجع تاني
لقوانين والمعلومات اللي عنده علشان يحاول
يتوقع كم كلمه اللي بعدهم طب وبعد ما
يتوقعهم يرجع تاني قوانين ومعلوماته
ويتوقع وهكذا عشان كده دايما
متقطعه عمرها ما كانت على بعضها
وبرضو مثال تاني على ايه اي محدود جدا هو
الاس تي ام كارجو الاس تي ام كارجو ده
عباره عن ميليتاري درون تقدر تفهم المنطقه
اللي حواليها من غير مساعده اي حد
من سنتين كده في 2021 الامم المتحده عمل
ريبورت لان الاس تي ام البرمجه ان هم
يحددوا التارجت من خلال كتيره وبرامج
معقده ويضربوه من غير اي تدخل بشري
بس هي محدوده جدا لتاسيسك التحديد
والتسديد وزي اي نانو اي اي ما يقدرش
المتبرمج عليه
هل ممكن حاجه زي كده تطلب لك برجر
نفس الكلام هل ممكن يعمل لك محشي
اكيد لا وهل ممكن اوبتيم سبوت يسيطر على
العالم زي ما كل الناس بتقول
اكيد الحاجات المحدوده دي مش هي اللي
هتشكل خاطر كبيره على العالم وعشان كده
العلماء وصلوا خطير جدا ممكن نوصل له في
اقل من 20 سنه ده هو جنريل اي اي
تخيلوا ان اوبتيم سبوت ذكاء الحادث جي بي
تي بمعلوماته اللانهائيه وال sm كارجو
بتنفيذ الدقيق اتجمعوا لتشكيل فريد من
نوعه ومش بس كده ده كمان بيفهم اللي هو
بيعمله مش زي النار اي اي
مرعب ده هو جنرال اي اي المدمر ده يقدر
يعلم نفسه يقدر يعمل اي حاجه انت بتعملها
وكمان يقدر يستخدم معلوماته وطاقته واكتر
من تاسكت
الجنرال اي اي زكي جدا بس في نفس الوقت
خطير جدا ده معناه ان الجنر اي اي يا اما
يحسن البشريه ويخلي حياتنا احسن بالمراحل
يا اما يدمر البشريه ويخلي حتن اسوا
بمراحل عنده القوه اللي يدمرنا بيها بس في
نفس الوقت عند القوه اللي يحسننا بيها
القوه بقى اللي هيستخدمها هتعتمد على
كيفيه استخدامنا احنا ليه وهتعتمد برضو
على تعليمه الجولز والقوانين المهمه
احنا لسه عندنا القدره ان احنا نبرمج
ونطور ونتحكم في الاي اي احنا لسه نقدر
نبرمجه عشان ما نسبوش يبرمجنا خلينا
نستخدم لتحسين حياتنا خلينا نستخدمه
لتحسين بتاعنا وحل مشاكلنا خليك فاكر
مستقبل لسه في ايديك اوعى تسيبه وما
ارتفيشنس ده فاصل شكرا